can you
[Music]
Icecrown
a monument to our suffering
[Music]
the veil between life and death
we're a usurper sits on a Frozen Throne
[Music]
but no King rules forever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
are unfit to wear this crown
[Applause]
- weird so power
power will be your person
this world is a prison
[Music]
[Music]
we'll set amaz
three
[Applause]
so now do the blue eyes make sense so
yeah that just happened we were once
told by King Terenas that there must
always be a Lich King and now for the
first time there is none Sylvanas
herself warned us that in the end death
claims us all well death is coming for
us and if we want to stand a chance we
are going to have to go where no living
soul ever has we are going to the shadow
lands the world that is the afterlife
for the entire Warcraft universe now
along the way we will get a chance to
meet some of the Fallen and learn their
fates but this is not a familiar world
full of orcs and trolls and dwarves this
is an ancient and mysterious realm that
predates the Titans themselves it is the
source of the power of the scourge that
we have seen true and it's the power
upon which death Knights draw but it's
also the origin of the noble Valkyr and
the spirit healers that guide us back
the land of the living when we pull a
couple mobs too many not that anyone's
ever done that
it's where spirits of nature go to begin
a cycle of rest and rebirth and so much
more let's take a look at this wondrous
world that we are set to explore
[Applause]
the jailer of the Damned the grim task
which I
fail
now the eternal veil screams torn
asunder
by
within the realm of shadow eyes the
darkest of terrors which should never be
set free
[Music]
the Shadowlands are infinite
terrors and beauty when
mortal eyes I wonder if to behold
all that awaits
[Music]
[Music]
the denizens of this realm are the key
to restoring the balance between life
and death if their trust can
god
[Music]
at the end
it's just beginning
[Music]
[Applause]
so world warcraft Shadowlands is coming
next year and it will be available for
pre-purchase today that is just a little
glimpse of this incredible world that
awaits us ahead of us lie many fateful
decisions because at its core
Shadowlands is an expansion that is
built around the idea of choice agency
and self-expression in the rewards you
pursue and in the allies with whom you
cast your lot I know you have a ton of
questions like what the heck is a
covenant
what is that tower that's sticking out
of the sky above ice crown what other
changes are coming into world of
warcraft and so much more so we have our
first panel for you at 2:30 on the
mythic stage the world of warcraft
what's next panel where we'll dig into
that and much much more also playable
here on the show floor we invite you to
journey into the zone of Bastion and to
begin to explore the shadow Lance
thank you all so much and it's gonna be
an incredible weekend ahead I can't wait
to share it with all of you and now it's
my pleasure to turn things over to Ben
Thompson on the hearthstone team
[Applause]
[Music]